[Applause]
hello ike how are you
i'm good i i'm getting closer and closer
to you guys in person last time was a
zoom in in my bedroom and now it's here
the next time it's gonna be there you
guys will smell me and there will be a
next time this is our second time doing
the show together i love doing the show
with you i'm such a big fan of all of
your movies um and i'm so excited for
this new cartoon but
what did you love about growing up in
chicago and like what's a a memory from
that
i mean chicagoans have a very good sense
of humor they like to make fun of people
and they love to get made fun of
you know like when you goof on someone
from chicago like someone in new york
might punch you someone in chicago is
like yeah that's true that's true you
got me um
but so so you know comedy kind of flows
through there you know growing up there
i think the most fun part was
uh we had amazing athletes like i grew
up right near wrigley field so i used to
see the cubs at like at the ihop and
then you you know i was a huge uh
chicago bulls fan you would go to a
restaurant and see
scottie pippen somewhere so i think the
sports of it all uh is really what
defines my childhood in chicago well
that's funny because like you yourself
played a lot of basketball right
we used to play if you grew up in
chicago in the 90s you just always had a
basketball with you you would always
dribble
and there was this kind of health club
where my friends would all play at and
they had games going on and every day
you would go and it'd be the same group
of guys at these games and there was
this one guy who always we always would
see him he was just a really nice skinny
dude and then like eight years later uh
he ran for president as barack obama
and uh won
so
yeah yeah yeah
so
there he is that's him and he's a he's
really good
um but it's funny because he's always
kind of like
very calm and cool and you know that's
he's unflappable but i remember very
well like
one time we were playing and he went up
for a shot and my buddy dave stasson
fouled him
and president obama came down and turned
to my friend and goes don't you undercut
me kid i am watching you and i was like
whoa
so years later whenever i would see him
i'm like oh wow i've seen that guy get
really mad before oh my gosh i mean i
can't
even believe um but uh you eventually
left chicago and you made your way to
los angeles yeah and you had been there
for a while and you had like a first
audition right
yeah i mean you know you moved to la and
you're like i'm ready for the big time
i'm ready for for stardom
so there's a commercial first for
quiznos and i get there and i'm so
excited i think i might have you know
worn like nice slacks
and uh i remember getting in there and
this director
he kind of looked at us and he was
pitching us as if he was
james cameron pitching avatar right like
it was so high concept and he's like
here's the deal guys um
quiznos oven toasts their subs
so the concept of this commercial is
you're a vegetable
or a piece of meat or cheese and and
when i yell action that is the toasting
starting to happen so do whatever
inspires you know do some some beet
poetry or start dancing
or do blue man group or improv stuff and
i was like those aren't really the same
but whatever and uh but i did it and i
was an onion
and i remember giving it my all and i
just started kind of like dancing and
screaming and as we walk out the guy's
like great job i'll see you tomorrow and
i remember calling my parents and being
like well guess what your son made it
i've made it in hollywood because i'm
going to be an onion in a quiznos
commercial so
call the relatives and then i went back
the next day and and i didn't get it
someone else was the onion and uh it
sent me into a spiral and i didn't have
another audition for uh a year and a
half so
never give up on your dreams kids
that's why i came
[Applause]
well you know
speaking of your family chicago aunt
party
um was inspired uh by a twitter account
yes yeah our buddy chris wataski created
this twitter account like 10 years ago
and it was just this really funny
inappropriate older woman who drinks too
much and and has had this like lifelong
party going on and we just thought it
was like kind of fun and you know a
funny person to interact with and we
never thought that it would really turn
into anything and then like a few years
ago netflix was like hey we want to turn
this into 16 episodes of a tv show and
we're like oh cool
and is there anyone in the show that's
based on anyone from your family or
childhood well i mean that's the thing
is that this character is an ant and
it's kind of loosely based off of our
friend chris's aunt but everyone
everyone has that person in your family
who whenever they show up you're like
nervous that they're going to say
something inappropriate and maybe ruin
the meal but they're really fun it could
be an uncle like right away you know who
it is right you have somebody i got
excited because i know i'll like this
person
yes if they're the inappropriate one i'm
like sit me next to them
that's the thing if you don't know who
in your family that person is it is you
and which is good that's good we love
that
and it is me yeah it's you it is it's
andrew it is it's aunt drew
yeah andrew's coming over oh boy i
wonder what she's gonna say yep um
that's basically what the show is about
it's it's it's also loosely inspired by
you too
i heard that some somebody somebody has
something for me i have no idea what
this is is this true it's a little
surprise it was flown in first class um
about three hours ago it landed there it
is there it is right there sorry angel i
had no idea you were gonna be there so
last time i was on your show
i taught i told you that for
thanksgiving i make stuffing with
pastrami so i have sent you my recipe
for
thanksgiving stuffing made with pastrami
oh my gosh here we go
look at that guys look at that look at
that and i would not stop talking about
it because my favorite food is stuffing
and i don't understand why everybody
calendars it into like one moment of the
year stuffing should be 365. we need to
open a stuffing-based restaurant in los
angeles or new york city where you come
in and it's three stuffings and a couple
daily stuffing specials and a dessert
stuffing and that's the whole restaurant
right
legit
oh my
gosh ike yeah this is incredible
i will start looking for financiers
immediately for our stuffing themed
restaurant first of all i would eat
there every day
we're doing it and everyone in the
audience you're all invited to the
opening night
we're doing it
it's happening
[Music]
you